my fellow Americans it is with a heavy
heart that I report that San Francisco
New York Los Angeles Chicago
they've all been reduced to rubble by
the deluge of leftist Tears following
the recent Supreme Court rulings on
Christian bakers and abortionists and
Somalian travelers the Chicago looks
basically no different but a difficult
day nonetheless for left-wingers we will
analyze this supremely good times that
we're living in and give a three cheers
for Donald Trump and cocaine Mitch
we've got a lot to talk about today
we're going to analyze everything from
there to the end of liberalism why
infant baptism is a violation of Human
Rights how the Democrats have nothing to
run on and we'll probably all drown in
the tears I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
in a special livestream this coming
Monday don't miss it Monday July 2nd at
7:00 p.m. Eastern Time we will be joined
by special guest Jordan
Peterson to celebrate Independence Day
God King Jeremy boring will host a new
edition of daily wire backstage with Ben
Shapiro Andrew Clavin and little ol me
to look back on our country's birth and
look ahead to its future subscribers
will even be able to write in live
questions for us to answer on the air
that's right writing your questions for
me Ben Shapiro Andrew Klavan the God
came Jeremy boring BAM and Jordan
Peterson again this is Monday July 2nd
at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific with
special guest
Jordan Peterson and I said do I need to
say that again we're gonna be serving
lobster it's gonna be a delicious dinner
you can find our special live stream on
Facebook and YouTube do not miss it okay
we have guys we've got so much to get I
we can't we can't go yet we can't cover
everything yet I really I'm too excited
I've been ready for this show since I
woke up and started dancing on my bed
this morning but before we get to all
the news of the day we've got to thank
dynatrap a wonderful sponsor that I use
every minute of the day in my apartment
dynatrap indoor fly light it may be the
greatest invention in the history of the
world I don't think that's an
exaggeration I'm really not kidding I
have these things all over my place in
Southern California we have an issue
especially when you're in LA proper of
flies in the summer flies just infest
especially certain parts of LA I think
it's because this is just demora by the
sea and so there's so much evil it
manifests nollies flies flying around
dynatrap indoor fly light actually works
it is the greatest bug catcher I've ever
used it's a fabulous summer time is
officially upon us and you gotta make
sure that you catch these little buggers
so we'd like to thank dynatrap it's the
leading manufacturer of outdoor mosquito
and insect traps it is I've been using
it now for probably a month and a half I
can't tell you the sort of stuff I find
but what's so good in the old days in
New York I would have that fly tape you
know and you'd catch like just giant
bugs and you just look like the lowest
of the low class people bugs hanging you
know too
in your house I don't know who thought
that was a good idea to just ornament
your homes with bugs hanging around
everywhere this is so good it looks
beautiful nice metal plug it's like it
works as a nightlight you don't see the
bugs but it catches them right now to de
visite dynatrap calm dy n a TR ap comm
enter promo code daily wired da I ly w
ir e that's dy na t ra p co m promo code
Dai ly w RI e dynatrap comm promo code a
lee weyer say 15% off their products get
it if it will change your summer for the
better get it right now dynatrap the
safe silent and simple solution to a
household insect control get ready folks
gotta take the cover off here i got it
just gotta take the cover off this come
blur get ready get ready for the deluge
you get this is what we have been
talking about you all thought I was so
foolish while I was building my arc of
tumblers you that you all made fun of me
didn't you well here it comes
here it's coming watch out No
[Laughter]
the devastation is so awful to watch I
we probably gotta watch that because
that doesn't even begin to capture the
dealership left us tears that are
pouring at today we could probably watch
the whole movie deep impact and it
wouldn't be quite and we got into it
really glad I have my tumblr I hope that
you have your tumblr too for those of
you I suppose who were listening you
know what that was the deluge of left us
tears let's let's get right into it to
begin at three cheers for Donald Trump
and cocaine Mitch McConnell three tears
hip hip hooray hip hip hooray hip hip
hooray for cocaine Mitch and Donald
Trump because they gave us Neil Gorsuch
cocaine Mitch that's not the only way
I'm gonna refer to him from now on
cocaine Mitch what he stalled out Barack
Obama tried to pressure everybody to put
his left-wing justice on the Supreme
Court Merrick garland and cocaine Mitch
said nope you're a lame duck president
we're gonna wait for the next guy to
come around and by the way people
thought oh it's gonna be Hillary just do
it come on Merrick garland is relatively
moderate oh no this is awful this is -
you're robbing Obama of his ability as a
president blah blah blah never minds
that Joe Biden advocated exactly the
same thing when George Bush was
president said no were you're a lame
duck we're not gonna take any of your
Court nominees cocaine Mitch stood firm
and I got to tell you folks he walks
like a turtle he talks like a turtle but
I got wise he's the devil in disguise oh
yes he is he is he's so he's such an
operator he Mitch McConnell you know
conservatives get frustrated with Mitch
McConnell because he probably isn't like
a rock ribbed
conservative ideologue I don't really
know that he has these hardline
conservative political philosophy when
he first ran for the Senate in the 1640s
he was a moderate he said he was a
centrist but what he's really really
good at is politics and right now it is
politically advantageous to be
conservative and he is one of the most
effective people at enacting
conservative public policy in this
country
he's done a really good job and and we
can thank him for this court appointment
it's where you know he said very wisely
he said you know the winners make policy
and the losers go home and this is some
of his conservative critics but he's
been great I mean it really really good
and President Trump for nominating all
of the Trump critics on the right they
said Oh Trump will never nominate an
originalist he'll never nominate a
textualist judge no way he's gonna work
with the Democrats no blah blah blah and
then what did he do he gave us a great
originalist judge in the vein of Antonin
Scalia whom he replaced really good
stuff so right now the Drudge Report
especially but a lot of conservative
outlets they're focusing on how the
Supreme Court upheld the travel ban the
president Trump's travel ban you could
call it Obama's travel ban it's the same
thing right I mean this is not the the
left is calling it a Muslim ban but
you'll notice that most Muslims in the
world can still travel to the United
States as often as they want this is a
ban from these terror ridden countries
that don't have proper vetting
procedures so we we just don't know
who's coming in and who's coming out
there this poor vetting has destroyed
Europe in the last 10 years and it's
caused some trouble in the United States
too this is a perfectly normal policy
it's a policy that the Obama
administration pursued as well and
they're calling it the Muslim ban
because they're just so upset but I got
to tell you other cases are more
important so it's true the Supreme Court
gave us a win here but it's much more
important that the Supreme Court upheld
three other cases within the last couple
of weeks and we'll take a quick look at
those the first one 73 year-old Vera
Nell Stutzman Washington State florist
who had served her gay friend and
customer for a decade I think and then
he said that he wanted her to arrange
flowers and flower arrangements for his
gay wedding ceremony and she said oh
well I don't that violates my religious
beliefs so I don't want to participate
and give my artistic endeavors to
participate in something that I consider
immoral and it was a really hard thing
and you know they cried and this she was
really friends with him and then this
guy is worse half not his better half
but his worse half and insisted that
they bring
suit and Su this woman out of house and
home and just destroy her life and
livelihood
fortunately the Supreme Court came
around and vacated the ruling that held
her in violation of the law and they
said no way she's non violation of the
law so that goes back to Washington
State this is a big win for religious
liberty in this country this is a huge
win you know the the leftist is really
hypocritical on this point right because
they the that guy what's his name the
spider-man guy and who was on Broadway
and angels in America
Andrew Garfield he comes out he says
come on let's just bake a cake for
everybody come on hey shouldn't we just
make a cake for it until they don't want
to and then all of a sudden it's yeah
we're gonna kick Sara Sanders out of our
restaurant yeah that'll show you that at
least the Supreme Court here is saying
if you have religious beliefs you don't
have to violate them that's a big big
win another similar case this came out a
little while ago is Jack Phillips he's
the Baker from Colorado they seem like
the same case it's the same thing
doesn't want to cater gay weddings and
it doesn't want to participate in them
with his services and the Supreme Court
found that the Colorado Civil Rights
Commission violated his rights and
discriminated against Jack Phillips
another huge win for religious liberty
you know this country was founded on
religious liberty even if you're an
atheist even if you were agnostic or you
don't really care and that is essential
to the fabric of the United States it's
no coincidence this place was founded by
people who all they wanted was religious
liberty the the pilgrims who came over
here from Leiden and the United Kingdom
they wanted to be able to practice their
religion freely it's woven into the
fabric of the United States it appears
again and again throughout US history
Ann Coulter once gave me this advice
back when she was talking to a group of
students who were you know you know that
fashionable thing where you're socially
liberal but fiscally conservative that's
like the first step on becoming a
conservative and so she was talking them
she said look even if you are in favor
of abortion if two candidates are
offering to lower your taxes and one of
them is pro-life and one of them is
pro-abortion vote for the candidate
who's pro-life he'll lower your taxes
more and what she meant by that is
there is a coherent political philosophy
and political philosophies that are on
the right side of the aisle so religious
liberty plays a big role in this even if
you don't really care you don't go to
church you don't whatever it's woven
into the fabric of the United States and
to oppose religious liberty is
ultimately a left-wing position even I
know you want to be fashionable or
something you say oh but I but no I'm
cool I'm like anything that's gay I like
that even if it's in violation of the
Constitution I like don't don't fall for
that trap that's a trap of the left and
the Supreme Court is given us another
day of freedom which is a big win then
probably the best one of all is in
California my own state when do we ever
get good news in California never I just
had to go and you know right now if
basically if you've ever owned a firearm
in your life the supreme court the
California State is gonna tie you up and
put you to the grand Inquisition it's
not great for conservatives out here but
we've just got a major win which is that
the Supreme Court says that the
California law the fact act is is not
constitutional so the case was the
National Institute of Family and life
advocates versus Becerra the Attorney
General of California and the the
question of play is whether this
California law is legit this law that
says that crisis pregnancy centers and
pro-life and non abortion providing
health clinics have to advertise
abortion the the fact act says if you
are a pro-life Catholic whatever a
Pregnancy Center you have to say hey you
can go get an abortion go get an
abortion you have tickets er you know
advertise it and the Supreme Court found
Justice Clarence Thomas I think we're at
the opinion of the court that this is in
violation of the First Amendment you
don't have to do that I don't have to
advertise for abortion this is a huge
huge win all of that before we get to
the one that everybody is tweeting about
and the one that everybody is tweeting
about is this travel ban travel ban is
Trump versus Hawaii the Supreme Court's
decision today reverses the Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals decision
the Ninth Circuit you know left of
Lennon of the pretty left-wing Court and
it reverses that keith Ellison that the
vice chairman of the
kradic National Committee not some wacko
not even just some congressman not some
activist on the street
he's one of that heads of the DNC he
tweeted out and he said the US Supreme
Court just ratified Donald Trump's total
and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering into the United States that
isn't true that isn't Indonesians can
come to the United States that's fine
Malaysians can come to unite yeah you
know people from Muslims can come into
the country if you're from Iran Libya
North Korea Somalia Syria Venezuela or
Yemen then it's going to be a little
tougher for you to come into the country
why because there aren't vetting
procedures in those countries right now
because they're basically all failed
States to come into the country now I
notice a few things about those
countries that are on the travel they're
calling it the Muslim ban one of the
heads of the Democrat Party is saying
it's a total and complete shutdown of
Muslims in the United States there's
North Korea have a huge Muslim
population is that I didn't know that
about North Korea does how about in
Venezuela is Venezuela like a hotbed of
radical Islamic activity I don't think
so not at all and and you know by the
way this first came about with a visa
waiver program improvement and terrorist
Travel Prevention Act of 2015 this was
during the Obama administration they
were identifying countries like this to
have restrictions on their travel it
makes perfect sense you can't you can't
have somebody coming over from a failed
state and and legitimately protect your
country the left tried to make a big
issue about it now what what keith
Ellison is saying is that it's all ghor
such as fault of course it's course is
just fault and it's because he's serving
his paymasters so weird he used his
paymaster who were courses just pay
masters just the US taxpayers right he's
a federal judge
he just gets paid what a federal judge
gets paid but then he keith Ellison you
know he's the first Muslim elected to
Congress and he compared this this
ruling to a Plessy versus Ferguson or
the Dred Scott decision all upholding
you know just destroying black people's
civil rights you know after 9/11 keith
ellison compared george w bush to hitler
this guy has a history of making these
insane statements but
right now a lot of the left is going
along with this there's oh this Muslim
band they don't know anything about this
ruling they don't know anything about
the history of this policy this is not a
huge deal right now even the people in
the commentariat on the left who are the
ones who were supposed to be like normal
about this and have some context Matthew
Iglesias at voxcom he tweeted out the
theft of Merrick Garland's Supreme Court
seat is legitimately the greatest heist
in the history of the world now I need
to the theft of Merrick garland see
Merrick garland was first nominated and
then you know we booted him because
Trump got elected and then we got a
justice corps such I've got to ask cuz I
not five minutes ago the left was
telling me that the 2016 election was
the greatest heist in the history of the
world and before that they told me the
2000 election was the greatest heist in
the history of the world and basically
whenever something happens that they
don't like they tell me that it's the
greatest heist in the history of the
world which one is it is this the
greatest one ever or is it not the
stolen see I got to tell you Matthew
Iglesias don't you make me play that Joe
Biden clip I'm not gonna do it it was
played so much where Joe Biden said this
president is a lame duck and we're not
going to deal with any of his Supreme
Court nominees don't make me play that
I'm gonna play that clip I'm gonna make
a whole episode of that clip if you keep
this up David Axelrod came out he
tweeted he said as one after another
five four rulings of this Supreme Court
on voting rights abortion rights the
travel ban and more or announced the
full meaning of the Senate Majority
Leader's unconscionable nearly year-long
blockade against the nomination of Judge
Merrick garland is manifest David don't
you make me play that Joe Biden clip
don't you make me do it because it's
just utter hypocrisy and and one thing
that's worth pointing out here is that I
don't think the the Merrick garland Neil
Gorsuch issue would have changed this
decision at all perhaps it would have
changed a decision on the abortion case
in California maybe it would have
changed the decision on the florist or
on the Baker I mean there are certainly
the it is pretty bizarre that there are
four left-wing judges who say yeah we've
got to compel you to participate in gay
wedding
we're gonna compel you to advertise for
abortion clinics that is pretty weird
but on this issue of whether the Trump
federal agencies can restrict travel
from certain dangerous places I'm pretty
sure Merrick garland would have gone
along with the majority of the court he
would have done exactly what Gorsuch did
and here's why this was reported I think
in Politico Ronald rotonda who is a
Chapman University professor of law he
wrote I don't think Merrick garland
looks at who is president I think he's
deferential to executive power to the
power of the executive branch and the
agencies to do what is certainly within
their purview he spelled this out at in
I think the 80s at a Harvard Law Review
article Akhil amar wrote about this and
talked about this long long before Trump
came around Merrick garland this is a
this is a fairly open-and-shut case I
don't think this is a big it's become a
big political issue because it's been
misrepresented by talking points but it
it actually isn't one of these you know
touch button issues so that's all they
have all they have are these sound bites
I'd like to point out the the pinnacle
of this the New York Times New York
Times used to be a newspaper is Andrew
Klavan points out and they are now
investing money creating these short
little cartoon videos like Cartoon
Network like Saturday morning cartoons
here is what the New York Times as all
of these public policies are up for
discussion up for grabs this is what the
New York Times is spending its time
producing and showing to its readers
I know words I have the best words
do you have a relationship with Vladimir
Putin I do have a relationship with him
and I think he's done a very brilliant
and amazing job he's put himself really
as you know a lot of people would say
he's put himself at the forefront
if you can't see what's going on on the
screen that's this cartoon of and
shirtless Vladimir Putin and now a
shirtless Donald Trump and they're
holding hands they're riding together on
a unicorn with with rainbows going
around they're both shirtless by the way
they're almost naked Trump is in his
underwear and they're smiling it's got
another kissing now they're kissing
really closely well Tripp and there's
fire between their lips and now you can
see their tongues or I can't even
describe this as graphic as it is
they're they're twirling around one
another their tongues in their open
mouths as they kiss and Donald Trump and
then cuts back to him and he's sitting
on his bed making kissy faces almost
naked and watching the television then
he shoots the TV that's with a with a
shirtless picture of Vladimir Putin on
the wall this is produced by the New
York Times this isn't something that
appeared in the New York Times this is a
production of The New York Times and
this gay obsession is really bizarre and
pretty ironic so you've probably noticed
this over the past couple years if all
of the left is obsessed with Mike Mike
Pence and Donald Trump and gay stuff all
of this gay imagery because this started
because Mike Pence you know however many
years ago said he might support some law
that as part of it gave certain funds to
certain therapy programs for people who
were suffering from sexual confusion and
they've turned this into Mike Pence
wants to electrocute gay people I don't
know how they got there that's what they
did
and and they're obviously the culture
right now is obsessed with gay sex
you've seen the the pride weeks over the
last or the pride parades over the past
couple of weeks that all anyone cares
about is gay sex not North Korea not the
Foreign Wars not the economy not
entitlement programs not marginal tax
rates not no none of the not health care
just
gay sex that's the only thing that
anybody can talk about that as as become
the sacrament and the idol to the left
but the irony here is that in this video
the New York Times is criticizing Donald
Trump they're insulting and they're
attacking Donald Trump this isn't just a
sort of saying oh I don't really like
his travel ban this is saying we hate
this guy and we're gonna make him look
like a big fat naked blob but the way
that they insult him the the part that
they think this is the best attack we
can make on Donald Trump is they call
him gay these are the same people
telling us it's it's great to be gay and
gay as beautiful and gay is wonderful
and gay is good and then on the other
hand they're saying yeah you know how
we're really gonna insult Donald Trump
yeah you're gay hahaha hey Trump you're
gay ah right they're like like you do in
second grade like school school kids do
when they're like 8 years old this ha ha
okay I don't know that they understand
the irony of that but that this is the
attack and it's so gross and so small
because the New York Times which used to
have some prestige I don't really know
why but you know it was a serious thing
they put good words together they're
good writers it's now basically become
the Occupy Democrats Facebook page there
is no real difference anymore between
the New York Times and the Occupy
Democrats Facebook page it's just they
spent who knows how much money producing
a video over a minute long with all this
illustration all you know totally
animated video to call Trump gay that's
it that's what they're doing that is so
pathetic meanwhile on the back in
reality the attacks that Maxine Waters
called for on Republicans are already
happening they're already manifesting so
Maxine Waters says yeah you're gonna go
out I want Democrats to go out whenever
you see a Republican whenever you see a
conservative in the street I want you to
get right in their face scream at them
scare them physically intimidate them
terrorize them go to their homes at
night scare their families keep their
families awake this the kind of stuff
she's saying it's already happening
there was a huge mob of protesters and
rioters outside of Stephen Miller's
apartment White House aide Stephen
Miller there's a camp out now
in Portland Oregon of occupy ice
demonstrators so the immigration
enforcement there's a camp out there
gonna occupy this whole this whole area
and it brings up this question or we
headed for a civil war and I say this
with a straight face because major
figures are suggesting it major cultural
figures and political figures Steve King
from Iowa I think he's from he's just
come out and said we're headed for civil
war where we've got Harpers Ferry is
coming up and after Harpers Ferry is
Fort Sumter Harpers Ferry was the raid
on John Brown in 1859 and then some Fort
Sumter was when the Civil War began 4:30
in the morning April 12 1861 when the
South basically started firing on a
National Army stronghold informs at Fort
Sumter and are we headed this way it is
true the left seems to hate us and I
don't think it cuts both ways I don't
think oh we all hate each other I don't
think it's that those ways I think that
the right considers the Democrats kind
of useful idiots as they've always been
useful idiots for Lenin and Stalin and
all the bad people on earth now they're
useful idiots for you know for Venezuela
for Cuba for all of our enemies Steve
Schmidt the former Republican Republican
who's now big Democrat he's basically
saying the dictator regimes in Venezuela
and Cuba they're better than the United
States they've always been useful idiots
but that's what the right thinks of the
left and the left thinks that the right
are evil vicious sick psychopath
monsters I don't think that about the
left the left does seem to think that
about us it's why the Nazi comparisons
are all over the place or are we headed
for civil war I don't think so I don't
think so I mean Steve King part of his
evidence for this is that there's a
occupy weirdo rally in Portland Oregon
that's the definition of Portland Oregon
it's just whacko occupy weirdo rallies
right that if that if they were sitting
down as a live like families were
sitting down having a tea party and
playing cricket that would be that would
be the stranger thing in Portland Oregon
so I don't think we have it in us I
don't think first of all the right has
all of the guns in this
country but I don't think that the left
really has it in them I think they're
just behaving like petulant children
petulant children can be really annoying
and they can be destructive for sure but
they don't pose an actual threat or an
existential threat they're just gonna
mess things up and draw in crayon all
over the wall but they just don't have
it in them even the name Occupy right
they don't even move there's a bad thing
they're kind of weak and I don't see us
heading for civil war I think
unfortunately our culture is too
decadent for civil war I guess that's a
good effect of a decadent culture is
that you're not really gonna all start
killing each other but we're just too
accustomed to luxury and and sitting
around and getting whatever we want on
our phones and we're just I don't I
don't actually think we're there we're
just in this kind of cultural malaise
but but things around us are going very
well
what are Democrats Democrats are the
party of talking points at this point
than the party of talking points the
total Muslim ban he's a Nazis Hitler
it's all it's all check your priveledge
check it's all just shallow talking
points you know the the the obsession
with the 2016 election was stolen this
the Senate or the judicial seat was
stolen it's a theft what about Russia
but then you ask them just like I asked
Tom Arnold on the show said what's your
evidence go a little further and they
fall apart they don't have anything they
only have talking points that that is
basically a good thing I think for the
ascendant right because right now we can
say they're B they're behaving like
crazy people sure they behave like crazy
people and everything goes well and all
the public policy that we want is
happening I think conservatives always
want to catastrophize things I think
we're gonna look back on this time in
history like a like a Carly Simon song
we're gonna be like give a song
anticipation we're gonna be there
they're gonna say my anticipation is
making me wait we're gonna look back and
we're gonna say stay right here cuz
these are the good old days you know
these are the good old days right now
the economy is doing great we're making
these huge political wins huge victories
for American liberty religious liberty
founding constitutional Liberty that we
thought were impossible two years ago
it's happening this is good stuff and
you shouldn't miss it I hope you're not
going to miss it
because you're gonna look back in ten
years
say I was pretty good it was pretty good
I wish I'd been smiling around them
these we should take the winds while we
can get them a lot more to get to a
Donald Glover childish gambino that guy
who made that stupid music video is
being accused of plagiarism because this
is America and I also wanted to talk
about the ends of liberalism the
philosophical end of liberalism which is
saying that infant baptism is a
violation of human rights and that
changing a baby's diaper requires
consent
these are serious things that the major
figures on left in some cases are
talking about we'll get to all that
before we do I have to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube you're gonna miss
childish gambino this is America this is
the Michael nul show tune in for this
show you can tune in for that
excellent backstage hang out we're gonna
have with Jordan Peterson you're gonna
be it want to ask questions you're gonna
want to ask questions in the mailbag
you're gonna want to see me
the Andrew Clavin show the ben shapiro
show the the conversation none of that
really matters you just need this guy's
because these are the good old days and
you're gonna be bloated and floating in
the good old days if you don't get your
leftist ears tumblr cuz you've got to
protect yourself man it is wet and salty
out there go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back
wet and salty that maybe that'll be the
new motto of the show it's wet and salty
out there the Michael Noel's show
Michael Noel's show wet and salty
that's make of that what you will so
Donald Glover is getting sued for
plagiarism I love this you remember this
song it came out a little while ago
this is America dupa dupa do and it was
like America is really bad and we just
all we do is kill people and it's racist
and it you know it turns black people
into just minstrel show puppets and it's
just been America's really bad and when
when where well it turns out he stole
the song he's getting accused of
plagiarism right now so he's being
accused of plagiarism by people who
listen to another song by Jace Hartley I
you're not familiar with Jace Hartley
neither am i but he did a song called
American Pharoah and just judge for
yourself what it the first one is
childish gambino this is America the
second one is Jace Hartley American
Pharoah see if you can tell the
difference
[Music]
[Music]
it's the same song it's definitely the
same song and Donald Glover who also
goes by Childish Gambino he's like the
worst thief ever because he kept part of
the name of the original in the name of
his song so without attribution without
acknowledging that it was obviously
influenced by in a good way or just a
ripoff of American Pharoah American
Pharoah by Jace Hartley this is America
by Donald Glover childish gambino
there's a great irony here right the
this is America song is all about how
America is just a place of theft it's a
place of oppression stolen labor stolen
property it's all guns right taking
taking things at the foot of a at the
barrel of a gun and then what does he do
he steals the song I don't maybe I maybe
I'm not giving him enough credit maybe
this is a real piece of meta or you know
is like really art about art and he's
really making this commentary I don't
think so I think he just stolen and now
Jace Hartley's been very nice about this
he said Harley said that this is you
know he's proud that it influenced the
song and he would have liked a little
shout out but that's okay whatever and
it is true it's really hard to prove
these cases I don't know that Donald
Glover is actually gonna have to pay
anything out and it's really hard not to
be influenced by other music especially
when the music is as bad as this the
fact that this music is so bad is
actually part of the reason why it's
hard not to steal so you know other
musicians this happens all the time
musicians hear a ton of music then they
write something they don't even realize
they're rewriting something else George
Harrison did this on the song My Sweet
Lord he basically he took
he was obviously influenced by the song
he's so fine by the chiffons he seems to
have been influenced by it
and by the way those two songs are way
more different than American Pharoah and
this is America but why is that because
those two songs have music in them those
two songs you know my sweet lord has
guitars and piano and it's got its got
melody harmony and rhythm right it's got
it's actually music and so does he's so
fine by the chiffons so they sound kind
of similar but you know they're little
differences all this has his rhythm and
talking it doesn't even have a melt it's
just talking right this is America dupa
dupa bad I'm Michael no soul I love ba
ba ba it doesn't there's no music to it
so when you strip you know if childish
gambino had stolen the beat the rhythm
of it but he had changed the melody in
the harmony then you'd say okay whatever
that's fine he's been influenced he's
building on something but he can't you
can't even do that if he takes the beat
he's got the whole song because there's
very minimal music in the rest of the
song I give great joy out of this this
thing it's bad news for the culture
because our art really has decayed I
talked about this a little in the
mailbag last week but since World War
one there hasn't been art in America
there's just been an T art this is an
idea that Jacques Barzun talks about and
from dawn to decadence after the first
world war all art becomes destructive or
ordi constructive or it just mocks what
happened in the past but in any case
it's just working on what's already
there and making it worse either by
parody or by playing around removing
pieces or by knocking the whole thing
down altogether like Dadaism and you're
seeing the fruits of that I mean you're
just or the the opposite of fruits of
that you're seeing the rinds and the
cores and the rot of that in in American
Pharoah and and this is America really
fun stuff though go go defend that
you're you're lucky Donald Glover that
you have an American criminal justice
system and then J sarli isn't just gonna
go out and beat you because you clearly
took his song before we go we've got a
couple minutes left here I do want to
talk about infant baptism this is a
thing you know this is normal way to end
the show you
talk about infant baptism there is
Astoria now that Mary McAleese Mary
McAleese from Ireland she was a former
president there she was president from
1997 to 2011 presiding over the total
decay and disruption of a formerly
Catholic country she has come out
against infant baptism
she said that infant baptism is a
violation of Human Rights
for those in the audience who are who
don't practice infant baptism
you know infant baptism is practiced by
the Catholics and the Lutheran's and the
Anglicans Methodists Presbyterians at
least to Bro a few others and it's been
practiced for oh now 2,000 years and you
know you put you you baptize little
babies into Christ and that's to give
them grace you know and endow them with
with grace and this is apparently a
violation of human rights this is the
logical end of liberalism and I'm not
saying leftism I'm not saying nihilism
or subjectivism or whatever like all
these things that we usually say in
liberalism from classical liberalism all
the way to the present this is the
natural end of that so here's what Mack
Elise said she said infant conscripts
who are held to lifelong obligations of
obedience you can't impose really
obedience obligations on people who are
only two weeks old and you can't say to
them at 7 or 8 or 14 or 19 here is what
you contracted here is what you signed
up for because the truth is they didn't
and it's not just her she's not just
some wacko Richard Dawkins said the same
thing he said that infant baptism is
child abuse
I teach raising your children and
religions child abuse this is the
natural end of liberalism because you
see these themes that are that come from
the beginning of liberalism in the 16th
century the modern era of emancipation
and individualism coming to insane
absurd fruition here at the end you know
st. Paul describes baptism as a
replacing circumcision which happens to
babies right this is the new you used to
circumcise your babies now you can
baptize them st. Peter writes about this
he says for the promise is to you and to
your
children into all that are far off
everyone whom the Lord our God calls to
him there that you you can even if
someone isn't at the age of reason or
isn't able to reason himself into making
a formal decision to go to church it can
be done for them people who are mentally
[ __ ] this can be done for them
people who are little babies this can be
done for them but even on the right now
and certain versions of Christianity
there's this idea that you have to make
the conscious choice as a conscious
individual to free and emancipate
yourself from the bonds of sin and go
and engage yourself as an individual in
the church and then and in the body of
Christ this is a total modern creative
crazy-eyed notion this also comes to
fruition when activists say that when
you change a baby's diaper they have to
give consent here's a here's an activist
with silly hair talking about that just
a while ago I'm gonna change your nappy
now is that okay of course the baby's
not going to respond yes ma'am that's
awesome I'd love to have my nappy
changed but if you leave a space and
wait for body language and wait to make
eye contact then you're letting that
child know that their response matters
oh god this is the end of liberalism
this is the end of individualism and
emancipation you know now on college
campuses I think you whenever you're
going to pick up a girl at a party you
have to have a notary public by you so
they can notarize the consent that it's
usually about a four or five hundred
page contract that you have to sign
before you can buy somebody a drink or
kiss them on the cheek or so you know so
would you like to go back to my
apartment I've got seven cameras on you
now so we have total proof and the
notaries over here it's all this this
obsession with the individual the
individual choice the individual
determination the individual
emancipating himself from the society
from the culture from the strictures
that society puts on you that's all
modernism and it all ends up like this
this is the logical end of that and
there is an alternative you know in the
modern era or the last five hundred
years that's all we focused on and I'm
not just talking about the left I'm
talking about classical liberalism to
the libertarians do this they say I own
my body I had a Jayson Stapleton from
that
his libertarian show came on and he said
I own my body but you don't own your
body that's just a fiction that you
begin with that's just a that's the myth
that you're choosing to begin your
political philosophy from but it is
nothing more than that it's just a story
that you tell yourself you don't own
your body you didn't make your body you
didn't come up with the idea for your
body you you got it through an act of
abundant grace it isn't you someone else
gave it to you somebody else made you
and you didn't save yourself either
you didn't redeem yourself you were
bought at a price by somebody else and
when the modern era has tried to forget
that or tried to erase that we tried to
create a society that denies that and it
did that through liberalism but
liberalism has an end this is the
craziness of it and therefore I think we
have to rethink some of our initial
assumptions and that way we won't end up
asking our little babies if they can
send to have their diapers changed or
you know be brought up by the UN Human
Rights Commission because we want to
baptize our children all right that's
our show today we got some really crazy
guests coming up soon and I mean like
crazy in the really good way not like
the bouncing off the walls kind of way
as some other guests may have been come
back tomorrow get your mailbag questions
in so we can answer them on Thursday on
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you